[MUSIC PLAYING]
- With that,
thank you all so much for
taking the time out of your day
to join us today. And
welcome to the Data Science Hangout.
If we have never met
before, I'm Rachael Dempsey.
I'm the host of
our hangout here,
and I lead our customer
marketing at Posit.
If it's your first
time joining,
this is our open space
to chat about data science leadership,
questions you're facing,
and getting to hear about
what's going on in the world of
data across all
different industries.
And so we're here
every Thursday
at the same time, same place.
So if you're watching this
recording on YouTube later and
maybe want to join us live,
there'll be a link below where
you can add it to your calendar.
At the Hangouts,
we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment
for everyone. We love
to hear from everybody,
no matter your years of
experience, your titles, your
industry, or even the
languages that you work in.
It's totally OK for you
to just listen in here.
Maybe it's during your lunch break,
or you're out for a walk.
But there's always three
ways you can jump in and ask
questions or provide your own
perspective on topics too.
So you can jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom,
and I'll keep an
eye out for that.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat
and just put a little star next
to it if it's something you
want me to read out
loud instead. Otherwise,
I'll just call on you to
jump into the conversation.
And then lastly,
we have a Slido link where
you can ask questions anonymously, too.
With that,
I am so excited to be
joined by a few different co-hosts this
week. So we're doing things
a little bit differently.
We have three people joining
us today from Biogen.
So I'm so happy to be
joined by Dan, Danielle,
and Anuja from the
Technology, Strategy,
and Innovation Group at Biogen.
And I first connected with Dan, I think,
on LinkedIn when he reached
out about a data competition they
were running. And so,
I'm so excited to be able to
learn a bit more about that today.
And I thought we could just
start with some introductions on your side.
I don't know if, Dan,
you want to get started?
Maybe share a little bit
about your role and also something
you like to do outside of work.
- Oh, boy, right on the spot.
OK, no, great. My
name is Dan Boisvert.
I work at Biogen,
which is a biopharmaceutical
company based in Cambridge,
but we're worldwide.
I've been at Biogen for 12
years, which makes me sound old.
I do--
things change a lot over
here, and they just recently changed.
But I do a lot of
technology strategy,
I do a lot of data strategy.
I really think about
our clinical trial data
and how we can best leverage that
both for our business but also just for
humanity for us to develop
better medicine and for us to
understand disease better.
So that's what I try to do.
And maybe I'll hand
it over to Anuja.
- Sure.
Hi, everyone. My name is Anuja
Das. I also work at Biogen.
I have been there for
about 2 and 1/2 years.
Maybe that makes me sound
young. I'm not sure.
But I
have worked over the past few
years on a variety of projects,
primarily within technology. And
I contribute typically from
a project management and
strategy contribution point of view,
but I've also been able
to delve into the technical
aspects a little bit.
My
favorite part of my job so
far is bringing people together who
speak different languages and have
a variety of skill sets to
work towards the same
end target and solution.
And so the Data Jam was
like a large-scale embodiment of that,
and it was fabulous to see. So
I'm very excited to talk about that today.
- Sorry,
I just realized I didn't say what
I do outside of work because I just--
I live here.
I'm an avid disk golfer.
So I don't know if anyone
plays disk golf on the phone.
But I'm an avid disk golfer. And
I also like to bake a lot.
I really do.
- So my
pandemic hobby was
to learn how to knit.
And so I've been trying to
do that, knit myself some
sweaters, which is in--
I'm in my grandma
mode. [LAUGHS]
But that's what I like
to do outside of work.
- I love that.
I might have to ask you
about that because our book club was
thinking about doing
that as an activity.
- Oh, yeah.
- Danielle, do you
want to go next?
- Yeah. Hi, everyone.
I'm Danielle Cloutier.
So I've been at Biogen
for almost 11 and 1/2 years.
So I've had many
different roles
at Biogen, but my
most recent one is
decision analytics,
specifically portfolio and
program modeling and analytics
to drive
decision-making strategic decision-making.
And something I like to do
outside of work, well, is I love--
obviously, love to
travel, specifically eat different
foods. But more recently, I did
take up learning how to golf.
- Love it. Are you all--
are all three of you
in the Boston area?
- Yes.
- OK, nice.
Well, no, we alluded to
the Data Jam a little bit.
So I thought it might be
helpful in the beginning to
just share a little bit about
the story of how that came to
be and maybe what
the Data Jam is.
- Danielle, do you
want to give it a shot?
- So the whole--
so we have a
couple of different community of
practices at Biogen,
one of them that Anuja and I
lead is the Data and Analytics. And really,
the whole goal was just to
get people across Biogen that are
passionate about data
and analytics together,
just to learn the different
ways that we work across the
different groups, find areas
of opportunity and collaboration,
as well as network.
And really,
the way the Data Jam came
about is things have been pretty--
has been pretty
interesting at work.
And so we wanted to try to find
a way to have a little bit of
fun, try to get
people together.
I think Anuja had mentioned she
loves getting people together. So do I.
So we decided,
why not try to throw together
a Data Jam and something that we
thought would just be something small
and fun turned out to be
something, actually, very big and
really show the passion that
people at Biogen has for data.
I don't know if Dan and Anuja
if you want to add on to that.
- That was pretty good
from my perspective. I think anything
that's successful, I think,
always happens something like
this. Danielle comes to me--
Danielle and Anuja come to me
in one meeting and say, hey,
I think we should do it like
a data competition. We're like, all right, sure,
let's put that together. Let's
see what that looks like.
And the
day you send it out--
like
I was hoping myself, 30
people would show up.
I thought if we had 30
people, we'd have like--
we'd have put five people on
a team. You have six teams.
You'd have a good
competition with six teams.
I think in the first
hour, 50 people signed up,
and then we just went into
panic mode of how we're going
to organize this,
which we could also talk
about because there's a lot there.
But really, I think it
starts on something small,
and then we just had such
a great team together to be able
to put something like this
together. It really worked out well.
-
So I think a lot of people
have ideas for things like this or
just ideas in general
that they'll bring to meetings,
but you all actually
made it happen.
How did you go from just an
idea for something to making it this real-life
event?
- Anuja, do you
want to take that?
- Yeah, I can take that.
I think
actually executing to
the point of getting
a data set and sending out
a form for sign-ups was
fairly straightforward.
We had a couple of ideas
of data sets that we could use.
And so we landed on one and
then just decided to go for it.
We had enough information to
execute, and we sent it out.
Where the challenge came in
was when we saw the rate of
sign-ups because people--
we realized, we
knew on some level,
but we really saw that
people love data and are passionate
about it and want to work
on a hackathon of sorts
or a Data Jam of sorts.
So I will say that we--
it got a little challenging when
we hit 200 to 250 because
our previous plan for how
we were going to run it
wasn't really going to
work anymore, given the numbers.
And so there was a lot
of planning on the fly.
So when we saw how
many people there were,
we decided let's do two
rounds instead of one.
And so it was part
of the excitement,
but it also was part of
the challenge of figuring out how
to accommodate the growing
number of participants. So yeah.
- I think part of it, too,
was that we actually had
support from our leadership to
actually go forth and do
this, and that helped a lot.
I think part of it, too,
was the fact that there has
been a lot of eyes just on data
in general for many
different reasons.
So I think that also helped.
But a lot of it, too,
is us just trying to figure
out how to even pull it off.
And then we did,
to be completely honest.
-
And I might clarify what
Danielle says because it's not
like we were given a task
to go run a data jam.
At some point, we just
had to make a decision,
like Rachel says. There are ideas
all the time, right? How do you
do it?
There's a little bit of
a leap of faith there.
I think you just--
what's the worst that can
happen? It's no one signs up,
and we just go back
to our day jobs.
What's the best thing
that can happen?
It's a whole bunch
of people sign up.
So there is just
a little bit of
boldness from this team to
be able to say, all right,
let's do it, let's give it
a shot and see what happens.
- I think a lot of it
too is we just asked.
It was like,
there's no downside
to expect. And so I think a
lot of it was we just asked.
And it seemed like
we were able to get
a lot of things,
a lot of yeses, actually.
- That's great.
I've been thinking about doing
something kind of like that at
Posit so that we could
mix people across
all different teams,
like Customer Success and some
of the open source package
developers, to work on a
common problem together.
And it's just been like an idea
floating around in my head.
So I was just curious how
you went and made it actually happen.
But I was wondering, for
the teams, were people mixed across
different parts of the
company or could people be--
it could be a group of whoever
wanted to join together?
- We decided to randomize it.
And so we had people sign up.
And part of the sign up
was asking what their capabilities were.
So is it that they've
never really coded before? Are they
experts or gurus? Do they
fall somewhere in the middle?
So we
defined four different levels
of competency and
had people describe
or self-identify
within one of those four.
And then what we tried to
do is when we did randomize teams,
we tried to kind of
spread the capabilities out. Honestly,
most people fell in the middle.
But we didn't want to put
all the experts together,
but also didn't want to have
a team that was all novices.
And so the Data Jam, of
course, was about data,
but another kind of primary element
was for people to meet each other.
And so we didn't want people
to just stay within their teams.
So this was an opportunity
to network outside as well.
- Yeah,
it was wild, the teams--
because we don't know
any of the people. Biogen
is a big company.
But the teams end
up wild, multiple
time zones, people in
like Buenos Aires, and China,
and Switzerland, and US.
And they gave them like three
weeks to go analyze some data.
They don't know each other.
They work in wildly
different departments,
some in manufacturing, some
in sales, some in R&amp;D.
So
like you're saying, Rachel,
a big part is giving
those people, force them into something.
And I feel like you get a lot
of benefit when people are
forced to problem-solve
together because that--
it creates a little bit of--
I don't know, a little
bit of conflict.
And when you get that conflict,
then you get people's different
opinions coming out and the
different viewpoints, then you
build on something together. So
I think that part was
really wildly successful.
And people had a good time
meeting people across the org.
- Yeah, thank you. Alan,
I see you asked a
question in the chat here.
Do you want to jump in?
ALAN: Yeah, sure.
Hey, everybody.
I think Dan was kind
of just speaking to
part of the question,
noting that folks had several
weeks to put something
together, and they were
kind of all over the place.
I'd really like to know more
about what did they make?
And how much structure did you
give them to lead into that?
Was this an internal
and external data set?
And did you give them a
bunch of specific problems,
or did you say, hey,
here's a pile of data,
find something fun and
interesting and make something?
And I'm curious about the array
of things that they made and
what the sharing--
with a great big set of 200
people sharing that back out at
scale is also
really challenging.
So how did that--
how did this conducting of
the rest of the thing unfold?
There's a whole bunch there.
Whatever is kind of
interesting to speak to,
I'd love to hear
about it. Thanks.
- Maybe, Danielle.
- Yeah, so we actually--
so we started with
an internal data set.
It was a survey that was
done a few years ago,
specifically around
data maturity at Biogen.
And so we had a data
set that was easy,
somewhat easy to
use and understand.
And then the way we set it
up was we gave the teams
a few weeks to
analyze the data set in
whatever fashion or whatever
type of tool they
wanted to use.
And the idea was to
generate insights.
There are a few key
questions that we had asked,
but other than that,
it was pretty much open
and then present it
not in PowerPoint.
So the challenge here was to
not use PowerPoint and to be creative.
And so what we did was
we had a few rounds of
battle rounds. We
posed it as like a
Eurovision, The
Voice type of
head-to-head knockout battle
rounds where we had groups of,
I think it was
five or six teams,
and then they would vote for
the one team to move forward to
the finale. So at the end, we
had, I think, 22 teams down to
five teams.
Is it five teams, Anuja? Yeah.
- Four or five, yeah.
It's kind of a blur there,
but we had it down
to five teams. And so
after that, we had like the
big finale where it was--
something that we did in
one of our auditoriums,
and we had all the
teams come present.
We were actually able
to get our executive,
some executive committee
members to come and do some
openings and some closing.
And we got our CEO there.
It was a really big event where
we then had people present in a Shark
Tank-style pitch about the
data sets and what they
would recommend to
better to have better data
stewardship and different types
of strategies with
data at Biogen.
And then we crowned
a winner at the end.
We had some
trophies and medals.
- I love how you're mixing
all these reality shows like
The Voice and
Shark Tank. And
I see Jesse asked a
question in the chat.
And I see a star
there, so I'll read it.
But the question was,
did the competition happen
during work hours? And if so,
how did you pitch the idea
to leadership to get them on board?
I know you just mentioned
that the CEO was there for the
beginning of the competition.
What did you appeal to in order
to get them to buy into the idea?
- Yes, we didn't ask.
We threw it out there. We
threw it out there and said--
I saw another question about did
we start with a problem and
have people solve the problem?
We just threw a data set
out there and said, look,
find some insights. We
left it really broad.
People came back
and said, well,
how much time should I spend
on this? And, of course,
data scientists can go nuts
on something like this.
So we tried to,
look, you only have three total
weeks to work on this thing,
and you have a big broad
team and everything.
So for the question
that was just posed.
We didn't ask leadership.
We asked people to volunteer
and
just--
try to keep it manageable. I
think I forget what we said,
total number of hours over
the three weeks, maybe around
8 to 12.
- I think we said it was
up to their discretion.
- It's up to their
discretion. Some did a lot,
but some did not so much.
- I think part of it,
too, was there was support for this.
I think we've been going
through a lot of changes, and
again, there was a lot of focus
on data. So part of this, too,
was a culture piece,
and I think the recognition that
this is a vital part of
working at a company is
the culture and the experience.
So I think a lot of that
also allowed for this to happen and
not really need
permission per se.
- I see Ted commented about
the data governance piece being so important,
and maybe this shifts a little
bit away from the Data Jam. But
what are some things
you've learned about data governance
through this or before?
- Yeah, this is a good
one. I can take this.
My role here is around
data stewardship.
People talk about data
governance, but personally,
everyone hates data governance
across the board, executives,
everyone. So I rebranded
it into data stewardship,
which I think evokes a little
bit more of we're all in this
together, and we do our own
stewardship of the information.
So what we ask people to do,
and I'm going to get it wrong,
what we asked. But we
asked for like an insight,
and we asked for a data
stewardship recommendation,
and we asked for
one other thing,
but I forget what that was now.
But we got a lot of stuff.
And then, the survey itself
was about how well does Biogen
steward data and how
well do we leverage data.
So all of the questions in
the survey were about this,
and then the topic
was about this, too.
So like what we heard was
probably not surprising to a
lot of people, but
data is hard to find.
It's hard to get
access to data.
And then we had a lot
of great recommendations on how we could
improve that. Anuja,
did I miss anything?
- No,
you covered it pretty well. But I
think, in addition to that, the fact that
I would say 80% to 90%
of the teams, which were incredibly
cross-functional, came to the
same conclusion, which was that
data is hard to
find and access.
And so it's not
a problem that's
isolated to a single
group. It's pretty
cross-functional, which I thought
was fascinating. It was expected,
but it was still very
interesting to actually see it.
- I think part of it, too,
generated a lot of ideas
on how to make it better.
And so that was some of the
pitches had geared their
thoughts and their pitch around, OK,
yeah, this is what it is.
But these are some of the ways
that we could work to improve it.
-
I'd love to hear some of
those ways to improve it because I'm
sure a lot of us are facing
that, too, if that's
something you can share.
- I know there was a lot around
kind of metadata-driven
cataloging,
ensuring that your data
isn't all over the place.
There was a lot of conversation
about the fact that
copying
data is something that happens
on occasion is and is obviously
not best practice.
So
I think the big ones that
we saw were essentially a catalog
to understand what
data even exists
so that we know what's there,
and then find a way for people
who need to access it to be
able to access it.
So that was a big
one that we saw.
-
And the other piece really
was actually having an
enterprise-wide strategy.
I think that was one of
the key things that was identified was
just needing some consistent
across enterprise and not just
specific to each of the
different individual functions.
- I'm trying to think
back, too. This was in May,
so it was a little bit ago, but
one of the ones that
resonated with me was not
to
create a partial catalog or
something like that where as
soon as you create
it. It's out of,
date and then it ends up
being another stale data asset that
you have, so really trying
to way, like Danielle was saying,
to enterprise it or
productionalize it and then find
ways to make sure that
it's sustainable long term because
I feel like that's where
we always end up with
a hiccup of how do we--
we could get it going,
but then how do we
actually keep it going?
- Is that your
team that's responsible for enterprise
data strategy?
I'm trying to remember the
name of the group Technology
Strategy and Innovation or
is that another [INAUDIBLE] in
a company?
- No, mine's like--
the piece that I'm in charge
of is the clinical trial data.
So obviously, at
Biogen, there's more
data than that. But
the enterprise--
it's just across all the
individual functions that they
do. Probably similar to
what it looks like at Posit,
probably similar to what it
looks like at everyone else's company.
- Yeah, there was an
anonymous question that was,
"from technology perspective,
how did teams interact
on the Data Jam?
Did they use common tools?"
- There is a variety.
And I think the
randomization of teams
spoke to what tools ended
up being used. So for instance--
We obviously didn't interact
with every single team.
But what ended up
happening was there was a
data communication person,
a person in charge of
creating the output,
a person who was more
of the programmer,
and then the person who was
describing what the approach would
be to actually solving the problem.
So it really depended on
what programming tools the people
within that specific team
were most comfortable with,
which kind of made it more
exciting because we had
people working in R,
people working in SAS,
people working in Power BI,
amongst others. And so
folks did rely
a lot on what we had in-house
just because it's
sensitive data, so we didn't want
to put it on external tools.
But there was still quite a variety
of what was used to produce the
end results and the solutions.
- Thank you. George,
I see you had a question
in the chat just now,
but maybe also
one from earlier.
So feel free to ask both there.
- Thanks. Yeah,
I was just wondering if
you obtained any feedback from the
participants on the different
aspects like the technology
side, what [INAUDIBLE],
especially [INAUDIBLE]
they may not really interact
with a lot [INAUDIBLE]
cross-functionally.
- Anija or Danielle, do
you want to take that?
- Yeah, so we did actually
do a post-event survey.
So a lot of
it was just understanding thoughts
and feedback on the format.
Would they participate in
something like this again?
I think at the end of the day,
there was a lot of really
positive feedback on the actual
Data Jam and wanting
to do it again.
And there were just obviously
some logistical things that we
had to deal with that we
could always make better for next time.
I think one of the
challenges was the different geographic locations.
I think that it was tough
trying to find teams that were
spread across when they could
actually meet because of the
different time zones. So
there were a lot of things that
we have on our list to think
about for Data Jam 2.0. But at the end,
we did get a lot of
positive feedback and a lot of good
ideas for the next one.
I don't know Anuja,
Dan, anything to add?
- No, I don't. Actually,
don't think we got too
much feedback in the way of
usage of tools. The
technology piece actually
seemed to work pretty well,
depending on what people wanted
to use. To Danielle's point,
it was more
logistics. And then,
there was also feedback around the
type of data set that we
could potentially use
for upcoming Data Jams.
So for instance, for
this one, we did surveys,
and some people love analyzing
survey data. Some people despise it.
So there were some feedback
there around what else can we
do moving forward and what
data sets could we use.
- I think that was
another good point.
A lot of people had
offered like, hey,
are we going to do this
again? Can you please use our data?
So that was pretty cool, too.
- Yeah, that's exciting.
Now you're getting people
thinking about, hey,
want to use my data for this.
I see there are a few questions
in the chat here, too. I think,
Kevin, you asked
one about different
formats that people--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I like that idea
of forcing them not
to use PowerPoint
because I definitely
find PowerPoint presentation--
I definitely learn less
from PowerPoint presentations than
any other format, I
think, that exists.
But I'm curious what other
formats people ended up using instead
of PowerPoint.
-
So some people use the Power
BI dashboards directly and went through that.
Others use some forms of
like Canva or animations.
There was one really cool
group that did these animations to
tell their story.
Anything? I know. I so a
lot of Power BI, Canva, animations.
- There were a couple
of shiny applications.
- Oh, there you go.
- Shiny--
- Yeah.
- Go ahead.
- There were--
so when you put this
question out there.
You never know what you're
going to get. You have to come
back. It has to be a
presentation under five
minutes, I think?
- Yep.
- Five minutes to explain
these three things.
So what are we going to
get? It was unbelievable.
We had people like
dressing up in costumes.
We had people do a set
of trivia questions.
- Or they played the Kahoot.
- And then we definitely
have some animation
to tell the whole story,
people walking through
the Power BI dashboard,
shiny apps, stuff like that.
But some really
interesting stuff.
And I think people
had fun with it,
even if they didn't have a big
epiphany of data
science in this.
But they were just able
to present something because we know
you need a lot of
skills for data science.
And so part of the storytelling
and everything is part of it to
getting the message across.
- So which formats do you
think were most effective?
- I would say the
funnier, the better
personally for this one.
But I think it really depends
on what message you're trying to convey.
If you're really--
I think we have some people
who did some really deep
statistical analyzes, and
they had shiny apps up,
and I think that was really helpful
to do that stuff. But to have--
for the big, broad
300-person audience,
I think you want
to go big and go
creative.
- Yeah, I think when we
think about the finale,
there were a lot of--
there are a few that
were powered BI,
but they didn't just do
Power BI. They had some
animations or the way they had
presented it was a little bit
on the more creative side.
- Yeah, I had this idea of
just making it accessible to
whatever tools people wanted to
use. If they wanted to
present it in Canva,
which is a tool I love
for doing design, too,
that they could use whatever they wanted.
- Yeah, and feel like--
- Go ahead.
- Oh, sorry, Dan.
- I was just going to
say it was less about
the output,
like one type of output
being more effective than the other,
but more so about how
you communicated what you were
trying to get at,
how you communicated your story.
So I feel like I
saw effective presentations across all formats.
-
And I'm just going to say
we're trying to make it as inclusive
as possible. So
it's not only for
PhD statisticians, of which we
have a lot here. It's really--
it could be a novice and
have no idea anything about data,
but you'd be maybe more
creative for the presentation
side, and you could
hear from them,
so a lot of cross-pollination
with different people
and really keeping it open,
use whatever you want,
do whatever you want.
- Again, I think the teams
also really leveraged the
skill sets and the strengths
of each member on their team.
So some of the people were
more heavy in the background,
and some of the other people
were more front and center in
terms of presentation.
So I think a lot of teams
use that to their advantage as well.
- That's really cool. Thanks.
Thanks for sharing that.
George, you'd like a
follow-up on that kind of--
- Yeah, actually,
I was wondering if
any of those creative
formats
have become normalized in
the culture because that's--
it seems like such a variety.
I don't expect someone
to just constantly dance,
do an interpretive dance
to their presentations,
but something along
the lines of--
a little bit more creativity
and going beyond the PowerPoint.
Have any of those
become a mainstay?
- Speaking personally, now, when
I try to do something,
I think about what can I
use other than PowerPoint.
I don't know if that's
necessarily across the board,
but it's definitely
something that I keep in mind
anytime I'm trying to present
some sort of visualization or
insights, is trying to be
a little bit more creative.
- Yeah.
- I think we definitely got
some feedback saying, oh, I'm going to
have to rethink about how
I've been presenting analytics results.
And our CEO is
definitely anti-PowerPoint, too. So
he likes the idea of
information being communicated in
some other way that's more--
like other people are
saying here, it's more accessible,
more easier to interpret.
- I'm feeling bad
for PowerPoint right now.
Some PowerPoints
are beautiful, too.
I see, Alan. You had a
question a little bit earlier.
Do you want to jump in here?
ALAN: Yeah, sure.
I was curious if there
were insights or things in
particular from what people
produced that could be pulled
back by the owners of the data
to turn into anything that
becomes programmatic or insights that
they can then act on.
That obviously would be a great
outcome like, hey, we get 100,
200 people together, and
it's a great engaging activity,
and it's super cool if the
team that owns that data could say,
hey, you found a
bunch of stuff,
or you started some ideas that
we can capitalize on and take forward.
Were they able to take
anything like that away?
- We'll let you,
Dan, speak about it.
- So I think a lot of data gems
go with this idea of--
here's this data set, or
maybe like Kaggle's like this,
right here's this data set,
figure out this thing for me.
And ours wasn't
exactly like that.
So we didn't know exactly
what might come out of it.
But I can tell you
what came out of it,
at least from my perspective.
I know a lot of people reached
out to some of the people who
were either shiny developers or Power BI
to get consults on how to do stuff.
Our CEO reached
out to us and asked
how do we fix this whole
data problem that we have at Biogen
that he just heard for
two hours during the Data Jam.
And I had one more,
but then I lost it.
Oh, and one of
the metadata catalogs that someone
recommended, they called it DASH.
I forget what it stood for,
but it was an idea of
just a metadata catalog.
And that's being taken up
by our computational biology in research,
and they're going to try
to push that forward next year.
-
Maybe this isn't something you can
necessarily put a number around, but
have you seen that
people are working
better cross-functionally because
of the Data Jam?
- Biogen is a big company.
I think we have
about 7,000 employees
worldwide. So I don't
know that we can
really get a pure
KPI on that one.
But I think you
definitely hear of some
interactions that never would
have taken place before.
And I think we've run these
two community of practices,
which I think are like this,
where you get people who
are passionate about something together.
And you have them talk about
different topics.
We have one around data stewardship
that I run and one about
Biogen analytics and data
community of practice,
which they call Bad Cop.
- Bad cop.
- --which Danielle
and Anuja run.
But we've definitely had
more people volunteer for leadership
in there, and we're
getting their voices in
to continue this conversation.
- I can say too that I've
gotten a lot of feedback on,
oh, thank you so
much for having this.
I was able to connect
with this person,
and now was able to
solve whatever issue or whatever
problem, or I was able to
get extra help on this.
So there has been a lot of
connections made that then help
somebody in their current
role or responsibility.
- That's great.
OK, Kevin, with the hard
question in the chat.
Do you want to jump
in here, Kevin?
-
You said your CEO asked you
how do you fix the whole data
problem. I'm just
curious, what did you say,
or what are you planning on
getting back to him with an
answer for that question?
That's a big question.
- It was a big question.
And we were like, OK, yeah,
we'll get back to you.
We thought about
it for a long time.
And
I think we've seen,
I'm sure you've seen,
I'm not sure what
organization you're in, but
a lot of these initiatives come and
go, and a lot of hype about
fix the world through data or
fix the entire business through data.
So we talked about this a lot,
Danielle, Anuja, myself, Sam.
And
the idea--
everyone wants to answer
to this one. OK, well,
the answer is it's complicated.
But I think the answer that we
really need to do is where do
we want to be as an
organization with data.
And we need to start from there
and then go down through
exactly how do we want
to improve our business,
and then try to connect
our data scientists,
our data innovators, into those
real business decisions or
business questions
that are there.
So that's the my
five-minute Shark
Tank pitch on
what you need to do.
You need to align the business.
You need to get them--
state their state
their position on data,
because otherwise
people like us,
we always just like
we do our initiatives,
we try to do our things and
it all hits some glass ceiling at
some point, which we're all too
familiar with. I don't know, Danielle, Anuja?
- I was just going
to say, I think,
the one of the things
that we had recommended,
and so we had worked on
putting this proposal together,
which is very inclusive of
what Dan was talking about.
But I think the first thing
was really just actually having an
enterprise-wide data strategy goal.
And it's something on
as a goal for our metrics to
at least have some traction
against at that
enterprise-wide level.
- One of the anonymous questions
from a little bit earlier was
what did you think about
the follow-through?
Are you collecting
and resharing
people's sharings?
Is there a follow-through
to hold another event?
- We did a couple of
things at the end to essentially make
people's solutions
accessible to all of Biogen.
So just for some context,
the finale following all the
battle rounds was an open
invite to everyone.
And so we had a
number of people join from various
different departments
who weren't necessarily
participating in the Data Jam.
And so one thing we
did was collect links to everyone's
Power BIs, and dashboards,
and shiny applications and
final findings and put them
in an accessible location
for everyone to view and see.
Again, because it
was a five-minute Shark
Tank pitch,
we couldn't necessarily
delve into the details.
And so this gave people
the opportunity to look into how
people did the analysis and
what the more detailed findings were.
So that's one
thing that we did.
We would love to hold another
data Jam because this one has
been so successful. We haven't necessarily
planned for one yet, but we're,
I think, still
hoping to do one. But
what has happened is,
I think Danielle mentioned earlier,
is people have been
coming with us--
coming to us with the data
sets that have the potential to spin
off another Data Jam.
And so we're
playing with the idea of
potentially doing one that's a
little more, maybe
hardcore data science for
specifically folks who want
to dive into the more intense
data science techniques
on a specific data set.
And so instead of doing a
big data jam like we did before,
maybe in the interim, we do
a mini data Jam of sorts.
And so there have been
several opportunities to
kick something off.
We just have to get together
and decide what that looks like.
- And I think Dan
mentioned our community of practices earlier.
So that's another avenue that
we try to keep this going,
the conversation going through.
- We've
talked a lot about--
in these data science
hangouts about data storytelling and
communication and sometimes
relaying that back to having
to do your own marketing.
And I was wondering if
you had any marketing lessons learned
throughout this process, too?
Although it sounds like you're
very successful because you got
way more people to sign up
than you thought you were going to.
- No, the marketing is key.
So Sam, who's not here today, but
she's our marketing expert--
and I do think marketing
makes a big, big difference.
I think when we sent out,
or we call it a Data Jam,
that sounds fun. We had
a lot of fun things.
We had a logo with a piece of
jam on it toast with jam on it.
I know with this--
- Data is my Jam
was the whole theme.
- Data is my Jam is
the theme. I know when
we had the finale, the
music was jamming by Bob Marley.
We were coming people
were walking in.
I think when we sent it out,
I know we had a one-page
flyer to describe this.
It had very little detail.
It said, work
with your colleagues.
And we really try to say
what's in it for them. Like,
what did they get out of
it? Instead of what are--
really explaining
what we're doing,
we're just kind of saying
what's in it for you,
you get to meet
your colleagues,
get to work on
something interesting.
- Oh, don't forget the
seven Cs of jamming.
- Yeah, I don't
remember the 7 Cs
collaboration.
- Creativity, collaboration,
there's a bunch of Cs.
And the last one we just
jokingly called for the seventh C fun.
- We couldn't come up
with a seventh one.
- Yeah, I think it was
fun for our team, too,
because all of us all four
of us love data and love getting
people together.
So we got really
creative and crazy with the way
that we were pitching it, too.
And so yeah, the
logo, for instance,
we did a couple of
stickers, we had
swag set up in the office
as much as we could
and tried to make it fun.
-
I really like listening to the
way that the three of you all
play off each other and answer
these questions and go back and forth.
It just sounds like you did
such an amazing job with this
event, thinking of all
the different parts
that make it what it is.
And I hope that you get got
the recognition internally for
this event and going above
and beyond to do that.
And I was just
curious to learn a little bit
more about what that maybe looked like.
- I think, for one thing, is--
our joined, and he was only
planning to join for 20
minutes. He ended up
staying the full two hours.
So that was really great.
And think, again,
there's a lot of positive
feedback afterwards,
and
people are looking
forward to another one.
So I think that's
the best recognition right there.
- Yeah, and I will say for
the four of us, we kind of
organically worked
really well together,
which I don't know how that
happened, but I'm glad that it
did. We each took on the
roles that came most naturally to us.
So for instance, Sam she loves
putting together graphics,
and she did marketing.
And then someone else would
take on the networking piece.
Someone else would take
on the logistics piece.
And so we each just knew
what our role was within the grand
scheme of things,
and that helped us to work
really well together from the
start. So not a lot of conflict
in the internal team, which is always good.
- We were joking if we
were like an actual team,
about all the awesome
things we could get done.
- So
we went heavy on the Data Jam
today and diving into all parts of that.
But I'm curious to learn a
little bit more about some of
the other things that
you're working on
as well and the everyday
business problems that you're solving, too.
- Oh, boy. OK.
- That sounded like a heavy
sigh. You don't have to answer.
- It's fine. It's complicated.
A big one that my
team is working on is
a reuse of clinical trial data.
So clinical trial data
is personal information,
obviously, but it's like
protected personal information.
It's very, very valuable.
We
study diseases that
don't have cures.
We study diseases
that don't have medicines.
We're trying to
find better ways to
treat the disease.
We're trying to find better
ways to measure the disease,
and that's all held together in
this clinical trial data that we run.
So a big thing that I'm working on
right now is how do we best leverage this?
It is immensely
complicated. There's many
privacy regulations, many
GCPs,
good clinical practice
regulations around
this, but I have this
feeling that we need to find a
way to use the data up to its
maximum potential
or maximum allowability
and no further.
But we don't--
if we just say, A, it's
complicated, I'm not touching
that. I feel we're
losing a big piece of
medicinal development.
So that's a big piece
that I'm working on.
I know Anuja is
helping me on that.
See what they have to say,
what they're working on.
I'm sure it's different.
- So for me--
oh, you want to go?
- Nope, go for it, Danielle.
- So for me specifically,
a lot of what I do is really
focused on understanding
the business risk for some
of our portfolio and programs,
so really understanding--
so what our
portfolio looks like,
what are the decisions that
we're trying to make to whether
we progress programs or
we terminate programs.
So a lot of it has to do
with really modeling and
understanding our
current portfolio,
the different decision
points, the investment points,
what's the risk,
what's the value,
and ultimately coming up with
insights for leadership to then decide--
leadership and/or governance
then decide what we--
what our portfolio should look
like, what are the programs,
what are the things that
we invest in. But again,
a lot of this is balancing
the business risk with
a scientific risk.
So lots of different more--
I'm focused a lot more
on the operational data
more than anything,
but a lot of it is
balancing out those different risks and
really helping decision makers
understand what their options are.
-
So I've been lucky enough
to work with several different
folks within analytics
and data sciences.
So am helping Dan with part
of his secondary use project. But
I think my biggest project
is around automation
for our end-to-end clinical
reporting and analytics space.
And so I help to manage but
also contribute to the strategy
of understanding what
can be automated and also
what should be automated because
there's a lot that
can be automated.
But we want to make sure that the
resourcing that we put into it is worth
the impact that it
will eventually drive. And so
part of that is playing
with the fact that people
work in SAS, but how do we
bring in additional languages?
How do we bring in more
additional analytics
techniques? When is
it worth doing that,
and what is the best way
logistically to also bring that in?
So it started off as a
smaller scope of work,
but it's kind of ballooned
out to be this massive initiative
that has been very
fun to work on.
So thank you all for
sharing. Really interesting.
I wanted to remind everybody,
with 10 minutes left here,
that if I missed any questions
from anybody in the chat among conversation,
feel free to just repost it
there or raise your hand here,
too. But I know
Bill loves this question,
and we have to ask it, too.
But was there any application
of AI or ChatGPT or
large language models in this?
- I can take that. So
we got a lot of questions of,
can I take this data and copy
and paste it into ChatGPT?
--which the answer is no.
--just FYI, if you work at
a big company that answers no.
But we have an internal
instance of ChatGPT that's secure,
and people did use that. We
had comments. So I think--
I forget how many people
took the survey, 300, something.
And people wrote
comments in there,
and so people were
doing sentiment analysis of the
comments and trying to pick out
some insights that were in the
comments, which was fun.
- Thank you.
Anuja, I really like that point
you just brought up about.
We talk about automation a lot,
but when is it worth
going through the process of doing
the automation and using
resources to do that? And
I'm curious how do
you figure that out.
- That's tough because
you have an initial
estimate of, yeah,
I'll be able to
develop up the macros or the
scripts needed to be able to
automate this in
x amount of time.
But then there's other pieces
that we need to factor in
around how long is it
going to take to adopt,
how long is it going
to take to scale.
And then there's a learning
curve associated with it as well.
So it is that's
something we've been--
as more people become aware
of the automation initiative, it's
automatically leading to
more ideas flowing in.
And so we're really having to
put a structure in place to try
and gauge from the very
beginning how much resourcing
is going to be used
in order to make this.
And so I know that
doesn't really answer your question,
but that's because it's tough to
gauge right from the very beginning
how much resourcing
is going to be put in.
But we do try to
account for both
development in addition to,
change management in addition
to adoption and set tangible
and achievable targets
intermittently.
- Yeah, I was going to
say queue up the XKCD,
but I see someone
already did that.
- I saw someone put
that in the chat.
- --already put it in there.
- I was like, it's got to
be the one I think it is.
- That's a good one
for us to all take--
- I remember that one, and I
didn't know where to find it, yeah.
- Nessa, I
see you had a follow-up
question from the previous
question. Do you
want to jump in here?
NESSA: Yeah,
I just wanted to ask
about the internal instance of ChatGPT
you're dealing with because,
well, I've been talking to
a bunch of hardware companies.
And I'm really interested in
how people are doing this. Is it
a web chat tool with a GUI like
most people access ChatGPT
in the real world? Or is it
all API-based?
And also,
is it accessible to people who
are not data scientists? Can a chemist
access this really easily?
- I don't know much about it.
I feel like when I saw it,
it was command line. So I
would not call that a GUI.
But I think it's like a
private Azure instance of
the GPT. But I don't
know too much. But no,
I don't think we don't have a
ChatGPT for Biogen where it's
a friendly user interface and ask
it any question. We
don't have that yet.
- I see--
NESSA: Cool. Thank you.
- Yeah, thank you all for
the great questions. I see, Alan,
you had a follow-up question
around more of the broader
community events.
Want to jump in?
ALAN: Yeah,
I'm just curious if there
are other things that connect
into a single
community of practice for folks
who participated in the Jam.
But also, more broadly,
do you have other events?
Is there other conscientious
organizing going on?
I'm just curious what that
looks like to keep these folks
seeing one another and
potentially connecting beyond that event.
- Yeah, I can speak for
the community of practice that we
run. So we try to have forums,
but what we were trying to have
at least every other month.
And so there's a series that
we have called Data Bytes.
And basically what it is
is either bringing somebody from
IT or somebody from the
community to talk about the
work that they're doing and/or--
more recently,
we had one that was
actually somebody that participated in
Data Jam and wanted to leverage
the Data Jam network to look at
their data and help
generate insights.
And I know we've
also talked about
doing some more collective
meetings across the
different communities,
so gathering all the different
communities together on a more
regular basis because data
Jam did bring a lot of those
communities together.
And so there are definitely
plans to start it,
to continue that.
It's been a little bit
hectic at Biogen lately,
so we haven't been able to do as
much as we wanted to. But I think
now that things are
somewhat settling,
we are definitely looking
at the next few key events.
ALAN: Well, thanks. I
hope those are successful.
It sounds like a
really good foundation.
- Bill, I see you
had a question around their
environment. You
want to jump in?
The question was
around different cloud providers. Are
you heavy into Azure or
AWS, one over the other, or
do you have mostly on-prem
data versus cloud?
And as always,
no worries if these are certain
questions that you can't answer to.
- I'm pretty sure I
have a little bit of everything.
- That's a good answer.
-
So I'll check here to see if
there were any questions that we missed.
Something I was curious about
when you were talking about the
different community events
and people who may be are
new to data science as well,
what does the training
look like for your team?
So if somebody who maybe--
I guess there's
two factors here,
onboarding for someone who
comes in with data science
experience or analytics
experience versus also somebody
who maybe hadn't used data
science before but wants to.
- Maybe Danielle.
- So a lot of it really
is on-the-job training.
So it's really just once
you working with the team working
with your manager.
But at the same time, too, I
know for some of what we hire
for, we try to be a
little bit diverse.
So a lot of times,
there are some technical
aspects that we are looking
for, but a lot of the times
for anything really data-related in my world.
I look for people that are
just genuinely curious and want to
solve problems. So I feel like
as long as you have those
two skills and that you're willing
to learn, that's
pretty much how
we get things done.
Don't know Dan--
and in your space if
it's any different.
But that's at least how
I handle things over here.
- Yeah, I think in the
data science groups,
we hire a lot of
more senior people.
There's not a lot of
entry-level roles there.
But I think maybe
you're also hinting at
although I hate the
word, a data literacy
effort of how you--
how does every single person
in the entire organization know
not to present a pie chart
and stuff like that.
And that's something
that we need to look at.
And I think these community
practices that we have are the
best way that we can really
do it. It's organic. It's leaning
on people already
wanting to learn and then
helping them get up to the next
level with what they already want to learn.
- I know we're speaking to
the communities of practice,
but there are some--
ours are a little more
general, but there are specialized ones.
So there's a machine
learning group
that dives into that
a little bit more.
And we're about to start
a data science conference
which will bring in
speakers and such for
people to learn a
little bit more there.
- Thank you so much.
I feel like I just have to
say this because Biogen's in
Boston, but I run the
Boston user group with my co-host
Kevin. And if anybody from
the team would be interested in
joining us, I just shared the
link to our event in the chat.
But we have a series of
lightning talks coming up,
and it'd be cool to do some
events with some others from Biogen, too.
Let
me double-check here on
any questions we missed. If
anybody in the last minute here
wants to raise your hand, feel free.
Well, thank you all
so much for joining.
It's really awesome to hear how
well the Data Jam went and how
many people were interested
in the event, too.
There's been a number of people
who've reached out to me around
holding their own
data competitions,
and I'm so excited to be able to
share this as a resource with them, too.
- Thank you so much for
having us. This was fun.
- Thanks, Rachel.
This is great. Yeah,
if anyone has any questions,
please feel free to reach out.
You can find us
through this or on
LinkedIn for sure.
- Wonderful. Thank
you all so much.
Have a great rest of the day.
- Thank you, too. RACHAEL
DEMPSEY: Bye. Thanks.